le secrétaire d'état chargé des
relations avec le parlement est l'invité
de preuves par 3 bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous jean marie le guen merci
d'être avec nous en ce jour de rentrée
parlementaire alors que le débat
politique ne s'est pas calmée ainsi le
moins qu'on puisse dire pendant la
période des fêtes d'ailleurs c était la
fête de l'exécutif y compris de la part
des socialistes
trois grandes questions au cours de
l'émission la première justement l'icône
taubira et l intouchable au risque de
fragiliser françois hollande sur la
question de l'autorité deuxième question
que vous posera marc bruel de l' agence
france-presse
le partenaire de preuve par trois est ce
la fin des grandes réformes du
quinquennat vous nous direz télé le
programme législatif notamment dans le
domaine économique enfin troisième
question vous fustigez la gauche
rétrograde celles qui demandent par
exemple aujourd'hui une primaire doit
elle consulté un médecin par exemple
comme vous le disiez en début d'année la
primaire même pas en rêve vous répondrai
tout à l'heure à perrine tarneaud de
public sénat qui vous interrogera
également sur votre vision d'une gauche
moderne que vous défendez au sein du
gouvernement et du parti socialiste
alors jean marie le guen vous n'êtes pas
encore sorti du casse-tête de la
déchéance de nationalité pour les
terroristes la solution pour l'instant
semble-t-il s donnait à christiane
taubira le statut de garde des sceaux à
la carte comme les dénonce aujourd'hui
laurent wauquiez non on me tout ça c'est
rentrer dans des polémiques
christiane taubira s'est exprimé à un
moment dans des circonstances d'ailleurs
un petit peu compliqué puisque c'est
vrai qu'à un moment le gouvernement et
éviter de savoir si le texte devait ou
pas tenir une clause constitutionnelle
bien on connaît sa position voilà l a
déjà dit elle même elle s'est exprimé
très clairement en disant qu'il pouvait
y avoir un débat avant que le président
ne tranche une fois que le président a
tranché
ceux qui ne sont pas d'accord ne sont
pas là et ceux qui sont d'accord sont
ceux qui sont toujours là sont d'accord
avec le à bourg-blanc berlin gmail
serait là pas d'accord et muette à côté
du premier ministre le tuer rien dans la
nation elle décèle dsk n'est pas
baroques quand même
depuis le début c'est le premier
ministre qui s'est engagé et qui a dit
qu'il défendrait cette réforme
constitutionnelle et ce n'est pas la
première fois ni la dernière fois que
dans un gouvernement il peut y avoir un
moment des réflexions qui ne sont pas
totalement homogène il ya personne n'est
un robot dans ce gouvernement c'est
évident un autre d'ailleurs un texte
elle va devoir appliquer l comme me
garder alors elle a dit ce qu'elle avait
à dire c'est à dire que une fricadelle
grand damne qu'elle condamne c'est le
problème n'est pas de condamner l a dit
que sa réflexion personnelle à un moment
à mener un certain nombre de réserves
une fois que le président a tranché il
tranche ça vous arrive tous les jours
dans votre rédaction non pas sur tous
les jours les gens dans une équipe il ya
aussi aux lectrices 10
moi je préfèrerais bleu l'eau d'accord
il avait choisi le chef 10 et bleu ces
bleus points mais comme tous voilà il ya
bien de l'autorité dans les rédactions
comme au gouvernement mais là je vais
tenir un procès en manque d'autorité du
chef de l'état qui est fait c'est un
procès absolument infondée qu'il
s'agisse de ce cas particulier puisqu'il
a tranché très clairement d'une part et
deuxièmement c'est un procès pénal mans
illégitime
en règle générale quand vous voyez ce
qui se passe dans la politique de la
france qu'il s'agisse de la politique
internationale les décisions qui ont été
prises à des moments très forts très
très difficile et donc est que quiconque
qu'il soit à travers les différents
attentats à chaque fois que le président
a dû s'exprimer a dû prendre des
décisions l'état d'urgence le soir même
quelques minutes après c'est horrible
drame
qu'il s'agisse plus un an plus tôt enfin
18 mois plus tôt d'intervenir au mali à
chaque fois le président la république a
pris ses responsabilités
donc ce ce procès vous savez il ya une
classe politique effectivement soit qui
a besoin de tenir des propos qu'ils sont
anti républicain pour se croire
volontaires d'autres qui sont les
spécialistes du coup de menton c'est pas
comme ça que les choses se font quand
les décisions doivent être prises par le
président de la république elles ont
toujours été prises avec force sa came
et la position quand même excusez moi il
fait du produit puisqu'ils avaient dit
qu'ils allaient défendre cette défiance
avec la garde des sceaux aujourd'hui il
dit je la défendrai seul
est ce que c'est une forme de mise à
l'écart de la ministre
des zus en aucune façon voilà lorsque
son il est intouchable invivable
parfaitement loyal et engagé jure dans
ce conseil des ministres où nous avons
présenté le texte de loi tel qu'il était
la ministre garde des sceaux a présenté
le projet de loi
enfin à man dans le projet de loi de
réforme pénale de façon qui est le savez
un projet de loi très substantielles en
matière d'augmentation des pouvoirs en
vente par l'état de la justice de la
police dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme
qu'on vous fait d'ailleurs y compris au
sein de la gauche pour fournir environ
vardar léger un procès c'est pas un long
procès c'est le procès inverse bien
c'est pour ça que finalement à force de
voir des procès de tous les côtés on
doit être sur une position alors il
passe il me reste encore un an tu en
voilà donc à chaque fois c'est elle qui
a défendu qui a travaillé qui a préparé
qui a défendu ce texte
et elle est une garde des sceaux
parfaitement actif je sors un an ferme à
sa place je sors à l'instant d'une
réunion où on avait un compte rendu
devant tous les responsables les
principaux responsables de l'assemblée
et du sénat sur l'état d'urgence
christiane taubira était là elle a fait
le point sur les enquêtes en cours
personne n'a songé une seconde à
contester sa présence d'une part et le
discours qu'elle tenait leur part il est
donc il ya est un jeu politique
j'entends bien oui vous permettrait que
dense et en particulier en plus de lutte
contre le terrorisme
on est autre chose à faire en tout cas
mon rôle c'est d'avoir autre chose à
faire que nous la corse est poli mais
nous nous dit que dans le contexte
actuel très chargé et très lourd que
vous rappelez effectivement on a besoin
de christiane taubira la justice
christiane taubira est une ministre
compétente est engagé quand on a besoin
pour la justice à la jeunesse écouter
gouvernement se compose il est là il
travaille alors écouter ce que dit son
sujet valérie pécresse
voilà ce qu'elle voit elle dans cette
opposition de christiane taubira à la
déchéance de nationalité
je ne comprends pas c'est de cacophonie
gouvernementale je ne la comprends pas
d'autant plus qu'elle finit par être le
symbole d'un pays où tout fout le camp
c'est à dire que comment voulez vous
allez dire à un lycéen il faut respecter
le professeur le proviseur
il faut respecter lors de l'autorité et
en même temps avoir une ministre de la
justice qui elle même ne respecte pas
l'auto rétro mon dos
aujourd'hui je ne vois pas d'autres
solutions pour restaurer l'autorité de
ce gouvernement et manuel valls que son
départ vous voyez le symbole selon votre
opposante valérie pécresse non mais
j'entends bien puisque c'est la question
vous m'avez posée depuis cinq minutes
donc on peut rester encore toulouse /
alors d'avancé vouée à la question mais
je suis désolé je vous ai répondu voilà
une fois que le président a tranché
christiane taubira s'est rangé à l'avis
du président donc il n'y a aucune kkl
demi elle se tait pour elle agit elle
parle tous les jours en conseil des
ministres en réunion de travail avec le
parlement sur les questions touchant à
l'état d'urgence
voilà elle travaille maintenant
j'entends bien ça devient dérangeant
qu'à un moment il ya des gens qui
puissent alors peut-être qu'il n'aurait
pas fallu que ce qui était sa pensée
sorte sorti ce mais elle l'a fait dans
des conditions particulières que sur
lesquels je n'ai pas ri l'aveyron le
gard oui mais sur la répéter mais vous
vous êtes quand même c'est drôle ça je
vous tienne de la langue de bois alors
je vais vous répéter dit voilà alors sur
laquelle affaire non mais si la langue
de bois c'est ce que vous voulez parce
que quand vous en avez pas quand il ya
quelqu'un qui parle avec sincérité sur
ce qu'a été sa position vous en faites
un procès donc il ya quand même un petit
peu de limites
je veux dire arrêtons cette affaire et
parlons si vous voulez bien des
problèmes des français plutôt que de
tourner deux pendant 10 minutes sur des
sujets sur lesquels je crois je me suis
expliqué assez clairement on va quand
même rester sur les questions de fond
mais ça va venir aux questions de face
que la sécheresse mais même encore sur
la deschamps je suis désolé mais la
méfiance par longtemps alors je te vire
à la 10e ou pas n'y sont pas compris on
va faire plus de langue de bois ce sujet
la question soulève beaucoup de
questions de la question ce n'est
beaucoup d'opposition au ps
écoutez par exemple la sénatrice ps
bariza khiari je pense qu'il y a dans
cette affaire n'est ce pas un passé
colonial
et que les miasmes coloniaux sont
toujours à l'oeuvre parce qu'on sait sur
qui ça va tomber ces déchéances de
nationalité et que ça envoie un message
délétère à une grande partie de la
population à qui certains disent vous
n'êtes pas vraiment il avait jamais été
vraiment français et la
constitutionnellement on leur envoie un
message qui n'est pas le bon alors c'est
quand même très fort elle parle d'un à
pensée coloniale oui mais je pense qu'il
ya beaucoup d'émotion autour de taillage
de ça j'ai d'ailleurs eu l'occasion d'en
parler avec bariza khiari est la même
elle même une histoire
qui évidemment compliqué autour de tout
ça non pas du tout je veux dire je pense
que là elle ressent une émotion
particulière mais en l'occurrence tu
n'en vendent constitutionnel qui ne met
en rien en cause c'est encore une fois
il s'agit de dénoncer et d'appliquer des
mesures à des terroristes gingras de
touché qui permet vous aviez proposé une
solution là des chances pour tous et ça
a fait pschitt pourquoi vous le
regretterez jamais proposé ça je dis que
c'était une proposition qui était sur la
table une piste ouais c'était une piste
visiblement elle avait l'inconvénient
majeur du point de vue à la fois un peu
juridique mais pas tellement mais
surtout sur l'aspect politique
c'est-à-dire jaillir de représentation
des droits de l'homme à savoir de créer
des apatrides et le prison la république
le premier ministre on dit et on le
comprend tout à fait qu'il ne souhaitait
pas d'accord que la france soit créer
des apatrides en voit aujourd'hui c'est
une novice à chaque fois qu'on avance on
il n'est pas interdit de réfléchir
et puis on voit bien que une solution à
des avantages elle a des inconvénients
une autre solution a des inconvénients
mais elle a des avantages en
l'occurrence la l'apatridie est une
ligne que nous allons décider de ne pas
franchir on avance peut-être sur la voie
des solutions parce qu'elle est certain
et estime par exemple qu'une peine
d'indignité nationale pourrait très bien
faire la faire c'est ce que dit le
sénateur socialiste jean-pierre sueur et
10 depuis le début de ce débat que là il
y avait une solution qui est l'indignité
nationale qui aboutit à priver
toutes les personnes qui sont frappés
par l'indignité nationale
les privés des droits civiques et de
beaucoup d'autres droits
donc c'est une sanction extrêmement
forte
je suis attaché au droit du sol je suis
aussi attaché à l'égalité et je ne
voudrais pas que l'on stigmatise les
binationaux alors voilà est ce que c'est
une bonne alternative se vaut selon vous
une peine d'indignité nationale qui
avait été validé par la résistance on le
rappelle jean marie le guen
oui enfin dans l'histoire on peut pas
dire qu'il ya une mesure qui est celle
j'allais dire de l'histoire de la
république et une autre qui ne serait
pas parce que la perte de nationalité la
déchéance de nationalité vous le savez
elle a été d'abord promu sous la
révolution française vis-à-vis des
émigrés de coblence
elle a été ensuite promu en 1848 contre
les esclavagistes par la révolution par
la seconde république française sur des
motifs qui était profondément
progressiste donc dans notre histoire on
a pu avancer ici à certains moments
l'indignité à d'autres moments
la république avec des arguments de fond
avec d'autres éléments la nationalité
avec des arguments de fond qui se
discute en l'occurrence ce qui se passe
j'en viens à vous répondre très
précisément c'est que le prison la
république devant le congrès le 16
novembre s'est engagé en parlant de
déchéance de nationalité et qu'il est
tout à fait question de respecter les
engagements qui ont été pris par leurs
fans ils n'ont pas d'autres mesures qui
seraient donc un camouflet pour le chef
de l'état si on vous entend bien donc si
je peux me permettre c'est pas une
question de camouflet pour le chef de
l'état s'est à un moment précis où
souvenez le 16 novembre il y avait 130
morts on pensait plusieurs centaines de
blessés
on pensait que et on pense toujours
d'ailleurs qu'il pouvait y avoir à tout
moment d'autres à tampa le président la
république s'adresse devant la plus
haute instance symbolique de la nation à
savoir le congrès ils l'expliquent deux
choses premièrement qu'il a l'intention
de mobiliser
les forces de l'état toutes les forces
de l'état pour lutter contre le
terrorisme ce soit au plan international
ou au plan national
et il explique aussi parce qu'il sent
que derrière l'émotion le choc la colère
qui existe dans le peuple français il y
à un risque
l'état et la société française peut
vaciller peut aller sur le terrain de la
haine et de la violence ou au contraire
aller sur le terrain de la résistance et
du rassemblement
et il veut le rassemblement et voulant
ce rassemblement il prend une mesure et
propose une mesure qui est une mesure
qui l'estiment qui n'est pas contraire
aux principes fondamentaux qu'il
souhaite mettre en oeuvre pour la
république mais qui à l'évidence est une
mesure qui a été avancé par d'autres que
les gens de son propre cadre à
l'occurrence quand la droite
on a dit que c'était la droite aussi un
mais si vous voulez bien à un moment
considéré que lorsque on est chef de
l'état que on a à gérer une situation
comme celle que je viens de vous décrire
on ne pense pas simplement à des petits
jeux où on se fait des croche pied mais
on pense simplement que le pays et
l'histoire vacille et qu'il faut trouver
des propositions qui sont des
propositions qui ne vise pas à piéger
les uns ou les autres mais qui vise tout
simplement rassembler les français est
en tout cas leur représentation et c'est
à dire en l'occurrence au delà la gauche
et la droite ce qui a été réalisé
gérard parce que les parlementaires dans
leur très grande majorité et la quasi
unanimité pas le front national pas
certains à droite mais une très grande
majorité des députés de gauche et de
droite se sont levés pour applaudir le
président de la république et ce moment
là c'était nécessaire à la nation ce
n'est pas simplement prendre nécessaire
ou particulièrement nécessaire à
françois hollande était nécessaire il à
la lnah s'il a besoin d'une large
majorité quand c'était nécessaire à la
nation alors vous avez raison de
considérer que par ailleurs à partir du
moment où on veut une réforme
constitutionnelle
il a besoin et les moyens de leur voté
et il s'agit pas simplement de dire je
veux une réforme j'avais une réforme
et puis après que ça ne soit pas votée
on l'a vu sur d'autres sujets d'ailleurs
où la gauche s'est brûlé les doigts à
avancer des idées de réforme
constitutionnelle qu'elle n'avait pas
les moyens de mettre en oeuvre par
exemple le droit de vote des immigrés et
donc je pense que là il est clair qu'on
ne peut pas simplement arrivé devant les
parlementaires en leur disant j'ai une
idée
c'est la meilleure et puis en fait ne
pas se donner les moyens qu'elle soit
choisie raisonnablement par les
parlementaires et donc c'est le sens de
l'à-propos zaccaron dans un moment
d'extrême gravité pour la nation moment
qui continue même si aujourd'hui il
semble fictivement parce que chaque jour
qui passe on s'aperçoit qu'il y à un
nouvel attentat en france ou ailleurs
dans le monde qui touche des européens
aujourd'hui on pourrait parler peut-être
qu'on parlera de ce qui se passe à
marseille on va parler parce que ça il
ya des choses quand même qu'il faut sur
lesquels il faut qu'on s'exprime
et puis à istanbul neuf allemands y est
c'est tous les jours qu'on nous assurons
qu'il y a quand même des choses lourdes
alors marseille marseille on découvre
les effets épouvantable de la propagande
sur internet auprès d'un mineur et que
peut-on faire
que peut faire le gouvernement fasse le
gouvernement met en place
des mesures qui demandent à faire la
chasse en quelque sorte sur les sites
internet à tout cela ce n'est pas encore
atteint parce que c'est un monde
extrêmement volatil que celui d'internet
il ya le fameux darknet que connaissent
les gens qui ont l'habitude d'aller sur
internet et donc il ya tout un travail
qui ne fait que commencer et
malheureusement et qui ne concerne pas
que la france parce qu'il faudra aller
toucher vraisemblablement l'ensemble la
communauté internationale et il faudra
que les entreprises
les géants du net des géants du net oui
peut-être un peu plus qu'ils ne le font
aujourd'hui dans ce combat donc nous
sommes partis pour un combat et donc
nous le menons auckland à cana sur le
net ou le menu un plan national mais il
ya encore évidemment des mailles dans le
filet et amertume par exemple ce qui est
terrible c'est qu'on apprend aujourd'hui
que les juifs de la ville sont invités à
ne plus porter la kippa
c'est un appel de leur communauté
comment est-ce que vous recevez ça et je
rends là bas c'est aujourd'hui ce que je
souhaitais que comme question qui me
semble important à dire que je suis
profondément bouleversé par cette
décision et je pense que c'est une
interpellation pour tous les français
est ce qu'ils se rendent compte que où
nous en sommes
parce que nous avons trop longtemps
c'est vrai depuis des années et des
années laissé se développer d'une façon
rampante un antisémitisme qui est
présent sur le net mais qui n'est pas
présent que sur le relais dans les
collèges en danger dans les cahiers etc
il va falloir extirper absolument ses
idées il y avait beaucoup de saisir du
sujet mais bien évidemment je pense que
la république n'a pas été suffisamment
vigilante de ce point de vue et il y a
devant nous un champ considérable pour
remettre les choses au point
la république ne peut pas le premier
ministre l'a dit d'abord le premier
ministre a été celui qui a mené rappelez
vous il ya quelques mois à un peu plus
d'un an maintenant le combat contre
dieudonné lorsqu'il s'est lancé contre
le fait que la justice ne pouvait plus
être inactive devant le phénomène
dieudonné il ya eu beaucoup
d'interpellations mais à droite à gauche
sur le fait mais pourquoi on s'aperçoit
maintenant qu' il y avait matière à
juger et à condamner mais qu'en plus
cela correspondait à un phénomène de
pénétration 10 des antisémites dans
notre société qui avait atteint des
degrés extrêmement grave où dit aux
citoyens de confession juive je leur dis
que demain disait effectivement donc ils
le font je n'ai pas d'autre objet
lanoline je ne mettrai plus la vie pas
dehors
je suis profondément bouleversé qu'est
ce que vous leur dites je suis
profondément bouleversé et leur absence
l'absence de liberté qui leur est donnée
est une absence de liberté qui nous est
donnée à nous tous les français et donc
c'est la république
alors je comprends et je vais évidemment
pas remettre en cause le conseil qui est
donnée par les responsables
communautaires mais d'un certain point
de vue je me dis je demande à nos
concitoyens parce que c'est certes une à
côté de l'état mais c'était une affaire
qui concerne toute la société
on va y a pas toujours un policier
derrière toutes les conversations les
propos les divagations antisémite que
l'on entend je pense que y compris dans
toutes les formations politiques
notamment aux différends extrême il doit
y avoir une clarification absolue aux
deux extrêmes mais je vais me bien rate
gex tout va bien au chaud bien dit qu'il
doit y avoir une clarification absolue
aux deux autres expressions
bien sûr je suis quand même profondément
choqué quand je vois qu'une fraction de
la gauche extrême mais de la gauche en
tout cas de la gauche de la gauche comme
on dit peut se retrouver dans des
meetings avec tariq ramadan
je veux dire il ya quand même à
clémentine autain pendant la campagne
des régionales
oui peut-être je dis que quand j'en
parle et la manière dont noël mamère est
intervenu c'est cet après midi à
l'assemblée nationale il faudrait parler
d'autres phénomènes sur ce que sont les
primaires à gauche
le fait qu'un gouvernement de gauche
donne la priorité à la sécurité et
entame justement les libertés c'est son
discours sécurité liberté la guerre et
tout y était passé et le premier
ministre a pu lui répondre
qu'effectivement nous n'étions
finalement en tant qu'homme
gauche et en tant que français d'accord
sur rien sur le constat nous n'étions en
rien d'accord avec les propos de noël
mamère c'était même pas une question de
savoir si nous partagions un peu ou pas
de nom c'était nous sommes totalement
une rupture les propos qu'il tient là
chargera je renvoie vos téléspectateurs
et entendants l'armée ont dit non mais
c'est pas une charge c'est qu'il ne faut
pas faire la guerre c'est nous qui
sommes des guerriers gèrent ils oublient
par exemple c'est pas qu'ils oublient
passe complètement sous silence et ils
dénient le fait comme aline sont
intervenus au nom de la communauté
internationale ont mené jure ya des
matchs de l'ensemble du gouvernement
malien pour sauver le mali de la
dictature et et plus pire que dans les
dictatures de l'énormité de ces
terroristes est donc je veux dire cette
gauche qui et complaisante qui est
passive par rapport à ces phénomènes
elle pose elle est très minoritaire aux
un problème la république elle pose les
noms mais je ne vois pas comment nous
n'aurions pas l'exigence de leur
demander de clarifier leur position et
sur la question de l'antisémitisme
ceci doit être extrêmement clair et bien
voilà on vous avait été très clair sur
le crg deuxième rang vouloir le noter de
preuves par 3 maintenant avec cette
question que va vous poser mare près de
l' agence france-presse
est ce la fin des grandes réformes
jusqu'à la fin du quinquennat on attend
dans une semaine à les mesures de
l'emploi pour l'emploi de françois
hollande
et puis quand même un nouveau texte sur
l'économie avec la satisfaction ou non
de certaines revendications du patronat
le marché du travail est bloqué en
france on a peur d'embaucher parce qu'on
ne sait pas licencier et donc il faut
régler ce problème là une bonne fois
pour toutes si voulez si on libère ça
vous avez une énergie
formidable france qui peut repartir
depuis gattaz est élu au medef
tous les six mois il leur propose la
même chose donc moi je ne sais pas si le
gouvernement va entendre le medef
je trouve qu'ils l'écoutent déjà
beaucoup nous avons dit que face à ce
que nous considérons comme du lobbying
patronal
concernant ces soi-disant contrat sous
plage il concernant la précarité et ben
il était hors de question pour la cfdt
de faire peser sur les salariés la
responsabilité du chômage
voilà marc p elle est avec nous notre
confrère de la lfp qui suit matignon
pour l'agencé bonsoir mark vos questions
à jean marie le guen sur la suite ou non
des réformes
bonsoir monsieur le ministre on sera
entendu le patronat et les syndicats est
ce qu'aujourd'hui le contrat agile que
demande le medef est envisageable
non je crois que ce n'est pas une bonne
proposition laurent bergé s'est exprimé
là dessus mais dans les propositions qui
sont aujourd'hui proposées par
l'ensemble des organisations patronales
il ya par contre un savon de choses qui
nous semblent aller qui sont tout à fait
convergent pas avec nos propres
réflexions sur l'apprentissage sur la
formation sur la rémunération sur la
pérennisation des prud'hommes
voilà il faut que l'on avance sur tous
ces sujets sans tomber j'allais dire
dans des mesures qui seraient qui sont
plus de nature idéologique ou qui sont
ultra libérale vous voulez dire non mais
que soit libérale ou pas vous savez moi
je sais pas les étiquettes
elles sont de plus en plus dépassés
alors c'est sans doute parce que je me
suis beaucoup intéressé à la chine que
je le leader du parti communiste d'inde
shaoping a expliqué que peu importe la
couleur du chat pourvu qu'il attrape des
souris
donc moi je suis plutôt sur la ligne
daxing des emplois ont attrapé des
emplois je trouve ça très bien alors
pour être prêt à les mesurer justement
les indemnités aux prud'hommes c'est une
bonne mesure efficace ou est-ce que vous
n'avez pas l'impression de faire passer
le message aux salariés que le
gouvernement rognent encore sur leurs
droits non vous savez connaissez bien le
dossier donc vous savez que c'est pas
mon rôle sur l'incertitude et pour le
salarié et pour le patron de ces
conflits juridiques qui débouche après
sur les prud'hommes donc on rogne
la marge d'incertitude pour les uns et
pour les autres voilà cette mesure et je
crois que psychologiquement elle est
fortement attendue effectivement par de
nombreux patrons de pme parce que
rarement à vrai dire dans 1% 2 % des cas
il ya des entreprises qui se sont
trouvés quasiment au bord de la faillite
parce que avaient été jugés dans des
circonstances particulières bon sachant
d'ailleurs que la jurisprudence n'est
pas du tout les mêmes selon les
départements les chambres preuve le mal
soit installé par départements et selon
les départements
la la la la jurisprudence n'est pas du
tout la même mais vous les cafés les
deux hommes un peu quand même non c'est
ce n'est pas cassé les prud'hommes ce
que serait formation homogénéiser c'est
sécuriser ses données de la
prévisibilité aux choses et donc sept
écartés des peurs qui sont en partie
rationnelle mais qui sont pas
complètement irrationnel dans la mesure
où il existe un centre de cas où il ya
effectivement eu des dérapages
là on a vu la majorité est déjà divisé
avec cette question de la déchéance de
nationalité vous avez des textes qui
arrivent des textes qui touche au code
du travail aux allocations etc
est ce que vous ne craignez pas de
d'avoir un blocage est ce que vous avez
la majorité pour faire passer c'est oui
je crois
je crois vraiment je pense que
d'ailleurs
les esprits évoluent beaucoup sur ces
sujets comme sur d'autres
sur la question de la nation en para où
on en a parlé tout à l'heure mais sur
tous ces sujets les esprits évoluent
très vite
vous savez je pense que les français
dans cette année 2015 qui a été si
dramatique j'essaie de formule il vaut
ce qu'elle vaut mais quand même je pense
que nous sommes vraiment rentrés nous la
france dans le 21e siècle en 2015 et que
la manière dont les questions se
posaient jusqu'à présent depuis
peut-être des dizaines d'années 60 ans
30 ans etc se pose différemment
aujourd'hui
regardez l'idée de nation pour la très
grande majorité des français est en tout
cas beaucoup à gauche la nation c'était
purement et simplement le droit du sol
pour une petite minorité c'était le
droit du sang et ça évidemment nous n'en
voulions pas et nous n'en voulons pas
vous parler aujourd'hui d'une nécessaire
adhésion mais aujourd'hui on en revient
à une conception de la nation qui était
porte porté par des philosophes ou des
hommes de gauche pensent à rousseau qui
est plutôt considéré comme étant un
philosophe des lumières et donc le
porteur de la gauche ou par renan qui
est un penseur sur la nation et je
prends cet exemple vous parler
d'économie mais voyez ce qu'ils étaient
il ya peut-être encore un an
une idée simple c'est-à-dire droit du
sol au droit du sang et maintenant on
est sur autre chose c'est la nationalité
c'est un contrat et quand quoi qu'on en
dise 99 % de nos concitoyens 90 % de nos
concitoyens sont sur cette position là
indépendamment de leurs positions sur la
révision de la constitution et bien sûr
les questions économiques et sociales
tous les rayonnages où ils lui disent
c'est que les français vol du
pragmatisme et de l'efficacité
il refuse l'idéologique des
conservateurs ou des provocateurs
voilà la réalité ce que veulent nos
compatriotes excellent et fiscales
concrètes un moment donné des gages
finalement à la gauche est ce qu'il ya
toujours besoin d'eux pour faire passer
ça les gens les mesures que deux clans
que va annoncer un peu dans la semaine
en ce moment le projet de loi il se
trouve que le projet de loi est très
ambitieux aussi au plan social vous
savez alors c'est encore difficile à
être mais le compte personnel d'activité
ça sera pour le 21e siècle en matière de
protection des salariés ce que la
sécurité sociale le fut
niveau du 20e alors c'est un concept
aujourd'hui on a du mal à l'expliquer à
tous les français je pense que beaucoup
de commentateurs savent de quoi il
s'agit il s'agit d'individualiser les
droits qui sont souvent distribuées de
façon collective et de façon pas
toujours appropriés là on va dire à
chacun d'entre nous vous avez le droit à
temps pour la formation vous avez vous
avez un compte d'épargné tant que vous
pouvez pour partie transformé en conte
formation vous avez des droits sur la
santé vous avez des droits sur les
vacances a déjà lancé on veut savoir
quel est le programme avance à caen dans
cette loi vous aurez à la fois cette
affaire du compte personnel d'activité
vous aurez la rall formes issues du
rapport badinter c'est à dire qui
réformera le nul 3 le droit du travail
lorsque vous aurez une approche qui a
déjà été avancées dans le rapport dit
rapport mettling rapport mettling c'est
un rapport qui essaye d'expliquer
quelles sont les relations sociales
à l'ère du numérique dans les
entreprises comment on compte pour ne
pas avoir 24 heures sur 24
être obligé de travailler etc je rentre
pas dans tous les détails mais qui donc
modernise complètement la proche du
droit social pour tous ceux et ils sont
de plus en plus nombreux des millions de
français qui travaillent en télétravail
en travail posté avec le numérique etc
puis vous avez le rapport qui va sortir
de pascal terrasse sur tout ce qui est
cette fois ci les liens économiques
entre les plateformes numériques
typiquement hubert pour que nos
téléspectateurs comprennent qu'elle va
être comment nous allons déterminer le
lien entre hubert et les indépendants
qui vont travailler avec hubert je
prends le cas du ber mais il y aura tout
un tas d'autres plateformes et donc ses
liens économiques là aussi on va
légiférer
voyez c'est de la matière enfin il ya ce
qu'on appelle le rapport barbaroux qu'il
avait des rapports sur la table mais on
a une matière ce que je veux dire c'est
que ce projet de loi je mets des des
tiroirs je mets des noms sur les tiroirs
pour que chacun puisse aller consulter
et compris sur internet de quoi il
s'agit le rapport aux barbares où je
crois n'est pas encore public
mais vous voyez il ya une matière
considérable d'innovation économique et
social et cette loi qui sera porté par
myriam el khomri principalement sera une
loi avec une densité de propositions
tout acteur aussi bas rhin justement
là-dessus il ya une incertitude qui a
perduré jusqu'à peut-être aujourd'hui
qui est qu' il y avait deux textes en
préparation du côté des manuels macro et
l'autre de mirabel connerie est ce que
vous pouvez nous annoncer ce soir que
cet exemple fusionner et pourquoi non
lee mécontents à nous confirme puisque
parce que on essaye de mesurer
exactement quelle est la partie de la
matière des uns et des autres qui est
prête
d'une part qu'est-ce qui est prêt qu'est
ce qui est urgent et qu'est-ce qui est
le plus opportun bien et donc nous
regardons prisme de ces trois éléments
pour savoir s'il doit y avoir deux
paquets de loi si on pour des raisons
d'efficacité on peut n'en faire qu'un
seul un seul tout de suite et un autre
plus tard bref la manière dont on
répartit les choses
si vous voulez se construit au prisme de
1 les propositions qui remonte y compris
celles qui sont faites aujourd'hui par
les partenaires sociaux puisque
évidemment nous tenant compte de deux de
leurs propositions et leurs réactions et
donc nous tenons compte sur le prisme de
l'urgence de l'efficacité et et de et de
la rapidité
une de de l'innovation un texte seul
n'ya plus vite ce sera plus simple
par exemple j'ai travaillé en même temps
non non j'attends de voir ce travail
n'est pas terminé vous avez raison ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que cette
hypothèse d'un texte j'allais dire
commun d'un texte unique et rassemble et
est sur la table
d'accord mais ça ne va pas marginaliser
un peu emmanuel macron on dit qu'il est
peut-être un peu insatisfait aujourd'hui
que peut-être sa vision des réformes
plus ambitieuses ne trouve pas les mots
ils sont prêts je pense que la politique
économique et sociale de ce gouvernement
est influencé par le ministre de
l'économie et la ministre du travail
d'hier c'est un travail conjoint ce sont
des gens qui pour le coup sont dans le
même gouvernement ont une vision commune
c'est d'ailleurs une génération à peu
près la même génération et donc je pense
que tout cela doit-être et est
convergent en avant rien on n'a pas bien
compris la volte face de la ministre du
travail qui a dit dans un premier temps
non cette année le chômage et la
perversion de la courbe et ce matin il a
dit au finalement il y en aura une
lorsqu'elle est la vérité écoutez je
vous rappelle ce je vous ramène à ses
propos n'ayons pas encore une fois les
français n'attendent pas de savoir des
prévisions sur on en a fait qu elle l a
calé quelle est votre vision à vous
parce que vous pouvez lire de façon
différente il y aura vraisemblablement
et nous pensons et nous l'espérons une
inversion substantielle de la courbe du
chômage mais on en aura pas fini avec le
chômage en 2016 ça c'est sûr bon ben
voilà c'est la gagne et l'abitur on va
dire presque une critique qui vous est
faite aussi celle annonces de françois
de françois hollande sur les formations
des chômeurs 500000 formation finalement
ces formations là elles ont elles ont un
objectif très clair c'est de faire
baisser le chômage pour permettre à
françois hollande ont représenté je
pense que je pense que d'abord vous le
savez très bien si c'est si si c'était
ça dont il s'agit on s'offre on se
fatiguerait - onfray les emplois aidés
comme l'a fait monsieur fillon à la fin
du mandat de monsieur sarkozy et puis on
accède ou non mais d'accord mais ça
coûterait moins cher en frais les
employés la question est de savoir je
pense que tout le monde peut être
d'accord pour dire que il y à un million
cinq je prends à la louche de nos
compatriotes qui sont non formés non
qualifiés 90
ray est ce ce goulet là c'est d'abord
dramatique pour eux et ensuite
évidemment pour la société française
parce que y compris s'il y avait un
retour de croissance très fort il ya une
partie des gens qui risquent d'être de
rester sur le bord du chemin et donc le
fait de s'attaquer ce que la société
française ne fait pas suffisamment c'est
à dire de s'attaquer à ce qui a été un
échec français considérable à savoir le
fait qu'on a laissé pendant des années
et des années 150 mille personnes sortir
de l'éducation nationale sans formation
et bien par an et donc nous nous
attaquons à cette montagne ou bien
longue d'ailleurs pas là la faire
disparaître en un an dans deux ans sans
doute que les 500 milles iront sur
plusieurs mois peut-être plusieurs
années et eux-mêmes ne sont pas encore
suffisants à la hauteur des besoins que
l'on dit et donc nous avons besoin mais
nous avons besoin de nous attaquer pour
des raisons stratégiques
peut-être même qu'on aurait pu le faire
plus tôt ça c'est une
c'est une reproche que je peux entendre
parce que finalement l'existence de ces
gens loin de l'emploi
ils sont là depuis 20 ou 30 ans 1
donc c'est un reproche qu'on peut se
faire mais c'est une telle montagne et
ça nécessite de bougez vous le savez
bouger la largeur de bouger les
comportements parce que pour trouver
l'argent il faut le trouver au niveau de
l'état oui mais il faut aussi aller le
chercher au niveau des régions et nous
entendons ce que veulent nous dire les
pas là où trouver l'argent c'est une
bonne question
aussi dans les dispositifs de formation
professionnelle qui sont peu tourner
vers les chômeurs il ya dans la foule
alors à propos de ou aller chercher leur
changer les habitudes françois hollande
annoncé un milliard hier pour le service
civique ou est-ce que vous allez trouver
cet argent alors qu'aujourd'hui même la
cour des comptes appelle à maîtriser les
dépenses publiques de la france parce
que nos choix souverains sont entravés
par le poids de la dette que
répondez-vous à la cour des comptes
aujourd'hui je répond d'abord que nous
avons les marges de manoeuvre pour faire
un certain nombre de choses au plan
politique et que le choix qui est celui
du service civique qui va d'ailleurs
j'allais dire se généraliser
c'est un choix stratégique pour notre
pays qui correspondait objectifs de
cohésion sociale et de mobilisation
sociale
on parlait tout à l'heure de l'évolution
du concept de nation voit bien que ce
concept il y a un besoin qui n'est
notamment dans cette année 2015 de de se
dépasser les uns et les autres au
service de la nation
c'est à ça que répond alors après bien
évidemment il ya des questions
financières mais c'est peut-être pas la
première alors des questions qu'il faut
se poser quand il ya besoin de me
bagarrer la marque toute dernière
question en toile était justement sur
une question assez financière il ya un
gros dossier social qui arrive qui est
le premier temps à paris ce midi c'est
la négociation de l'assurance chômage la
nouvelle conversion de l'unedic qui est
lourdement déficitaire donc on va faire
encore des économies pour en gros mieux
alors que mieux verser les allocations
aux chômeurs et est-ce que vous êtes
prêts comme liar liar d'ailleurs un peu
sous-entendu manuel valls à dire la
question de la durée et du montant des
allocations chômage se posera en 2016
oui je pense que ces questions là
doivent être traités avec courage c'est
compliqué par les partenaires sociaux
mais on voit bien que autant il est
extrêmement difficile de diminuer les
aides aux chômeurs dans une période où
le chômage est encore très élevé et en
même temps on sait bien que à la fois un
peu pour des raisons financières dont
vous parliez mais aussi pour mobiliser
plus de moyens sur la formation des
chômeurs il est assez vraisemblable
qu'il faut un petit peu changé les
paramètres de notre assurance chômage
s'il n'y a pas d'accord des partenaires
sociaux le gouvernement interviendra
quitte à parfois baisser des allocations
chômage et le gouvernement sera amené à
ce moment là
à intervenir mais c'est une solution qui
signerait quand même la faillite de la
discussion sociale est là dans ce pays
donc je renvoie la responsabilité quand
même vous savez bien les retours des
syndicats c'est un chiffon rouge en tous
les cas merci de la précision est
apportée merci marc perry internautes
arrivent maintenant pour la troisième
partie de preuves partons avec cette
question sur la primaire à gauche on va
y arriver avec vous jean marie le guen
l'hypothèse donc a été relancée par un
appel de personnalités ce que vous
répondez
est ce que vous leur répondez même pas
en rêve à ces pétitionnaires
plus généralement d'ailleurs perrine à
vous interroger sur le nouveau logiciel
de la gauche qui s'impose selon vous
mais écoutons d'abord le sociologue
michel wievorka qui est signataire de la
pétition et qui n'a pas du tout aimé
votre façon de l'envoyer chez le médecin
lui et les autres à cette façon de le
traiter
il s'adresse directement à vous vous
avez indiqué que ce qui demanderait une
primaire à gauche ferait bien de
consulter
j'ai trouvé la formulation un peu
abrupte et j'aimerais savoir si vous la
maintenait totalement même sous une
formulation plus adouci où vous si vous
considérez que la manif est l appel qui
viennent d'être annoncées et qu'ils en
sont aujourd'hui
alors je vous parle a presque vingt
mille signatures si vous maintenez cette
façon de considérer les choses
et est ce que vous pouvez vous êtes
porte parole du gouvernement nous
confirmer que l'elysée ne donna pas la
moindre suite à l'appel qui est formulée
ne discutera pas ne fera pas connaître
autre chose qu une fin de non recevoir
voilà michel wievorka interrogé par
géraldine beys walo annonce est un
proche de martine aubry alors voulu dire
de consulter qui il a un médecin même si
non non c'était une formule qui venait à
la fin d'une d'une interpellation que
qui me venait à l'esprit
il faut le prendre amal absolument pas
c'est peut-être de temps en temps mon
défaut professionnellement médecin je
pense simplement que il ya un moment où
comment dirais-je d'illusions peut
devenir un problème avec la réalité
il ya une partie de l'illusion qui est
utile parce que à l'idéaliser elle
permet de mobiliser la volonté mais il
ya une partie à un moment de le degré
d'illusions peut avoir un risque de se
couper de la réalité
alors moi je dirais même pas en rêve la
primaire alors justement c'est cette
formule que je trouve évidemment si en
rêve bien sûr que si mais même temps si
j en rêve six ans rêve on voudrait mais
si si michel dubord kapoor clichés j'ai
beaucoup de respect évidemment parce que
c'est un intellectuel de très grands
renoms et d'ailleurs je dirai un mot sur
sur son travail
si vous voulez bien me sens prêt
parce que les sciences sociales je le
fais tout de suite par un 6 travaille
beaucoup sur la déconstruction vous
savez les sciences sociales françaises
sont les spécialistes après après
foucault après après d'autres et là on
est on est toujours un petit peu c'est
un travail utile intellectuellement de
la déconstruction
je pense que la déconstruction du
leadership du président de la république
ne paraît pas extraordinairement utile
par les temps qui courent donc je
reviens ou le sérieux des morts puisque
je reviens je reviens primaire elle
figure aujourd'hui dans les statuts du
parti socialiste mais ne s'applique pas
au président sortant à françois hollande
oui je le crois c'est ce que j'ai
toujours pensé et ce que je crois aussi
si vous voulez c'est que quelle primaire
parlons nous c'est une prise de la
gauche s'avère de maquereaux un
mélenchon par exemple par exemple voilà
on peut le souhaiter
enfin certains peuvent le souhaitez moi
je pense que vu par exemple ce que j'ai
entendu cet après-midi avec noël mamère
jusqu'au dit monsieur mélenchon tous les
jours et je sais plus dans quelle
catégorie ranger un certain nombre
d'autres qui sont à la gauche de la
gauche
enfin il a précisé que je pense que nous
ne sommes pas non mais justement je
pense que on ne peut pas demander ni à
noël mamère ni jean-luc mélenchon ne
dira pas donner de noms mais l'engin
voyez bon de se rallier à ce que par
exemple à ce qui serait la désignation
de françois hollande et d'abdiquer ce
qui est leur position politique ou d'une
façon totalement radical permanente
absolue et totale
il critique deuxièmement moi je ne peux
imaginer que monsieur mélenchon soit 10
désignés dans cette primaire je le dis
d'ores et déjà je n'imagine pas de me
faire représenter ce que je pense
politiquement par jean luc mélenchon
donc je n'accepte pas qu'on désigne
pourquoi tout simplement parce que je
pense que au point où nous en sommes
la discussion elle se fait pas dans un
cadre qui serait commun sous prétexte
que nous aurions des il suffirait que
nous réfléchissions à l'intérieur de
cette donnée qui est la gauche qui c'est
une donnée enfermante mais qui de
mémoire en plus flou parce que jean luc
mélenchon à mon travail
vos arguments lui n'imagine plus
aujourd'hui voter sachant j'essaie
d'expliquer c'est ce que j'ai essayé
d'exister
non seulement jean luc mélenchon de
division mais attendez c'est par ici
je pense que il y a une façon avérée
pour une certaine gauche de pratiquer la
division vous l'avez constaté tous les
jours donc je veux dire ça sert à quoi
de dire ah ben voilà on va se on va se
réunir on va tirer au sort et puis il ya
quelqu'un qui va faire des envieux une
garantie l'abandonnèrent la primaire
aujourd'hui si vous voulez il suffit pas
de se réclamer de gauche pour dire qu'on
est d'accord sur un projet sur une
stratégie la réalité si vous prenez
l'ordre l'agenda réelle des problèmes du
pays
ce que je crois être moi personnellement
l'agenda premier à savoir que la
question de la république et de l'unité
de la république me paraît la question
première
ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'il ya pas des
questions sociales d'ailleurs mais
l'unité de la république me paraît une
réponse première pour être efficace par
rapport au terrorisme sur tous les
sujets qui nous sont posées et lutter
contre les extrémismes et c7
cette orientation là elle n'est pas
celle de jean-luc mélenchon et elle
n'est pas celle de noël mamère elle
n'est pas celle d'un certain nombre de
gens s'ils pensent que pardon qui vont
être vos alliés alors pour la campagne
2010 est
mais quand on voit aujourd'hui si vous
voulez la cote de popularité du chef de
l'état est-ce que ce socle de popularité
est suffisant pour faire campagne en
2017 et surtout l'emporter au décès
qualifié nationale avec une gauche
complètement éminent plus que diviser
c'est la question des questions
fondamentales quand même et c'est une
question fondamentale mais quand je
regarde la gauche je regrette cette
division mais je les constate et je sais
pas des divisions simplement liés à des
comportements il avait moi c'est pas
liés à des comportements c'est lié à des
projets qui sont totalement opposés
aujourd'hui il ya une fraction de la
gauche qui dit sur l'état d'urgence sur
l'islamisme sur la lutte contre le
terrorisme
c'est plus mélangées
cheaib et sur des sujets par exemple
toutes ces critiques qui sont des
critiques radicales se sont pas les
critiques secondaire on va écouter
généralement l'un des tenants de ces
critiques si vous êtes d'accord c'est
pierre laurent avec qui vous avez fait
campagne pour le second tour des
régionales je le rappelle en passant son
l'écoutant l'écoutent il ya un risque
très sérieux que la voix de la gauche
celle qui refuse la déchéance de
nationalité celle qui veut une vraie
politique de lutte contre le chômage et
celle qui en a assez d'entendre dire
ministre de gauche de l'économie
s'appelle emmanuel macron et bien cette
gauche là il faut qu'elle ait une
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
il faut qu'elle parle obéit donc battre
marine le pen mais surtout pour apporter
des solutions et c'est ça qu'il faut
construire avec des forces diverses avec
qui bat marine le pen là en l'occurrence
puisqu'on parlait monsieur laurent
décret lui-même qui soustrait il retrait
de sa primaire
l'essentiel des forces socialistes
françois hollande etc
donc il faut faire une primaire avec la
gauche de la gauche mais c'est son droit
le plus strict mais ça montre bien que
là le discours tenu par michel wieviorka
encore une fois dont je comprends le les
moules le le caractère sympathique de la
démarche est un peu irréaliste on voit
ça je constate que me laurent ni
mélenchon ni ma mère vraisemblablement
non l'intention de participer
alors après d'autres charges
d'opposition tous les jours mais nous
les socialistes et il y avait bien
d'avoir des élections
on a remarqué vous reposiez remarquer qu
effectivement laurent d'un message je
suis pas c'est une donnée si je dirais
mais ce qu'on comprend c'est que
maintenant vous regardez du côté du
centre droit vous rayer vraiment d'un
trait de plume toutes les personnalités
de la gauche que nous avons évoquées à
d'un trait de plume je dis que je ne
veux pas m me mettre d'accord avec elle
a priori sur un projet maintes n'accorde
on vous regarde et nous avec lui ça d'un
trait de plume je dise bonjour à vous
regarder du côté du centre droit on
regarde pas le centre je pense que tout
ça parce que vous me parlez de la gauche
et je l'aurai vous répond sans langue de
bois pour vous dire oui il ya des
divergences qui sont sein de la gauche
mais je sais aussi qu'il n'ya pas que la
gauche et la droite et à l'extrême
droite
et c'est pas simplement le problème de
la gauche et qu'à l'intérieur de la
droite
je ne crois pas du tout à l'unité de la
droite non seulement pour des querelles
de personnes
mais parce que sur le fond il ya des
divergences fondamentales
donc je ne crois pas que on va faire des
petits calculs
pour répondre à votre question il faut
aller regarder vers le centre je pense
que encore une fois cette année 2015 est
en train de bouleverser complètement ce
21ème siècle est en train d'écrire une
nous
l'histoire ou les éléments de
rassemblement et de divergence ne seront
plus les mêmes ceux qu'on a connus
depuis d'accord on essaie de rendre
vraiment de rassemblement aujourd'hui
serait plus proche quand même dit
centre-droit nombre d'arrêts dont
certains au centre droit est pas de tout
ça pour écrire le programme justement
pour cette élection présidentielle donc
vous évoquez inconsidérés français
aujourd'hui sont dans une grande attente
quand on voit ce qu'ils disent dans les
sondages on s'aperçoit une chose les
détermine c'est que le rapport
gauche-droite est moins déterminant qui
a une très grande volatilité et qu'il
cherche un certain nombre de réponses
une l'organisation d'un certain nombre
de réponses je prétends que ce que doit
faire la gauche
en tout cas la gauche tels que moi je la
vois et je ne réfléchis pas simplement
avec mon oeil gauche je suis français
donc je regarde ce que je crois
nécessaire pour mon pays et pour les
valeurs que je défends je suis un
républicain parce que je suis de gauche
et donc je veux défendre cette
république c'est république elle est
mise en cause à la fois par le
terrorisme à la fois par des
comportements sur notre pays qui sont
des comportements communautaires qui
atteignent au fonctionnement de la
république sur nos territoires et dans
certains milieux elle est mise en cause
aussi par l'extrême droite cela justifie
me semble-t-il que en priorité numéro 1
de mon action politique
je mette la république c'est république
elle a besoin de cohésion sociale et
c'est pour ça que je pense que en tant
qu'homme de gauche je suis mieux placé
que d'autres mais ça ne veut pas dire
que je n'accepte pas que d'autres
viennent se mêler à ce combat
républicain
nous avons quelque chose à dire pour
défendre plus que d'autres encore le
modèle répulsion et moins de temps pour
le dire cette année parce que le temps
va être créée par la prière primaire à
droite mais la primaire à droite
elle nous permettra pourquoi voulez-vous
que moi je ne dise pas et je ne sois pas
dans le débat politique qui aura une
primaire à droite mais nous ça nous
permettra de nous exprimer
parce que ce qui importe aujourd'hui
dans cette primaire à droite c'est
l'avenir du pays si on n'est pas deux
camps séparés fusse-t-il d'ailleurs deux
puisque maintenant on est plutôt trois
camps séparés
on est on est pas il n'y a pas des
frontières donc on l'on peut parler on
peut dire ce que nous approuvons
ou ce que nous désapprouvons ce que nous
redoutons et ce que nous espérons y
compris d'autres français qui n'ont pas
les mêmes idées politiques que moi je
fais partie d'une république où les gens
parlent
voilà et donc je suis rim est ce que
votre nouvelle réflexion politique
finalement ça passe aussi par la
construction d'un nouveau parti
socialiste c'est ce qu'il faut ouvrir la
maison socialiste
oui bien sûr c'est ce qu'a demandé jean
christophe cambadélis et recomptent mais
on essaye de le faire d'ici la fin
janvier c'est lui qui est aux manettes
pour cela mais effectivement lorsqu'il
parle d' alliance populaire
on voit bien nous avons dès lors nous
l'avons dit rappelez vous il ya manuel
valls et jean christophe cambadélis l'on
dit il ya environ 18 mois en disant qu'
il fallait absolument complètement
changé les fondamentaux de cette maison
elle celle ci c'est que le parti social
et c'était fini chardon valse samba les
lis aussi voilà il en est le sel de la
terre donc il y en a la conscience
il en alla conscient bien sûr qu'il faut
aller vers un dépassement les formes
d'organisation du parti socialiste ne
correspondent plus alors à la vie
sociale d'aujourd'hui les clivages le
fonctionnement tout ça ne correspond
plus est bien bien évidemment qu'il faut
qu'un renouvellement profondément des
forces politiques des générations il
faut que nous changions pour moi c'est
en fait un programme sur les dix qu'il
faut changer tout est compris le
personnel politique et les français ne
veulent plus revoir par exemple le match
sarkozy hollande on le dit aussi
mais ça fait partie des données qui
existe dans la tête des français se
trouve que les institutions de la vème
république font qu'on a un président qui
va gouverner jusqu'au bout et réformer
jusqu'au bout et que parce que d'un
certain point de vue il incarne au delà
de sa personne une fonction il est notre
candidat naturel
mais c'est vrai aussi que c'est lié à
l'histoire et aux institutions ces
paliers si on ne peut pas faire et c'est
aussi une différence que j'ai on peut
pas faire table rase arrêter la
politique pendant bus pour aller en
salaire sur ce mot merci merci j'avais
merci crazy
bonsoir à tous la semaine prochaine
c'est emmanuelle cosse d'europe écologie
qui sera votre placement sera très vite